pierre pour le groupe est républicain
monsieur le premier ministre
l'article 58 du projet de loi de
finances réforme en profondeur dès 2016
le calcul de la dgf la dotation globale
de fonctionnement versée par l'état aux
communes et aux intercommunalités
sans même parler du fond cette
précipitation est inacceptable
la réforme n'a été précédé d'aucune
concertation véritable avec les
associations d'élus
à commencer par l'association des maires
de france les simulations rendu public
hier pour mesurer l'effet de la réforme
sont mensongères
il a dit que 69 % des communes
ils gagneront mais c'est faux il n'a pas
été tenu compte de la contribution au
redressement des finances publiques
un prélèvement de l'état sur les
finances des collectivités locales en
réalité il n'y aura que des perdants
puisque de toute façon vous avez décidé
de diminuer la dgf des communes et des
intercommunalités de 2 milliards d'euros
l'année prochaine
enfin au delà de ces effets financiers
votre réforme va intervenir au plus
mauvais moment en 2016
il va falloir aussi dessiner une
nouvelle carte des intercommunalités et
mettre en oeuvre les transferts de
compétences prévus par la loi notre
monsieur le premier ministre trop c'est
trop
c'est une menace pour l'investissement
et la qualité des services publics
locaux
écoutez ce que vous disent les députés
de notre groupe mais aussi certains de
vos amis retirer l'article 58 du projet
de loi de finances est préparé avec les
élus locaux dans la sérénité le dialogue
une réforme digne de ce nom
monsieur le premier ministre on se
grandit tout jeu
en reconnaissant ses erreurs allez vous
le faire merci monsieur avait repris
hier la parole est à madame marylise
lebranchu mise la décentralisation et de
la fonction publique
merci à madame le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur pardon
pardonnez moi monsieur le député dire
que les simulations sont mensongères
c'est vraiment ne pas prendre en compte
les calculs tels qu'ils ont été
présentés déjà depuis plusieurs semaines
personnellement si j'ai un regret sur la
façon dont nous avons bâti ces
simulations c'est que le cfl au mois de
juillet alors même que les principes de
la réforme avait été acté n'a pas voulu
pour des tas de raisons à prendre le
document l'étudier en fer commentaire
donc c'est le seul reproche qu'on peut
se fermer au moins
admettez le il est totalement
transparente is an la réforme de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement est
totalement indépendante bien évidemment
de la baisse des dotations mais ce qu'il
faut noter c'est que grâce à ce projet
de réforme est alors même que nous avons
déjà réussi à partir de la dsr delà des
issues de la detr c'est à dire des
dotations de solidarité aux communes les
plus pauvres à faire que les communes
les plus pauvres ne subissent pas à
cette baisse la réforme elle a un seul
principe qui est la justice nous sommes
tous d'accord nous sommes tous d'accord
et reprenez vos débats de des médias
pour dire qu'aujourd'hui la dgf est
injuste et cas même type de population a
même type de revenus moyens elle peut
aller de 1 à 2 le seul argument que nous
trouvons totalement recevable en
revanche c'est qu'effectivement les opci
sont en train de subir de grands
changements à bas bruit mais que la
carte territoriale de la france est en
train de se ré écrire alors peut-être
oui il faut adopter les principes de la
réforme
adapter à la nouvelle carte de
l'intercommunalité merci madame la
ministre la parole est à monsieur à
l'afld